plat voilà pourquoi vous souhaite
éliminer carole et carol ann a pas de
niche haut tu fais de la varappe tu as
besoin d'avoir les prises il a la classe
ouais je veux dire que j'avais bien aimé
l'intervention de patrice c'est tout
question de génération sont sûrement les
couilles molles suffit pas je plaisante
je plonge je suis très sérieux du sel
gédéon touché des couilles dans la
jungle oh bah oui tendez vos bras et
montrez vos boules à patrice au mettez
votre bermuda c'est un programme
familial s'il vous plaît je plaisante
les boules au risque pas de faire du riz
au lait loin nous on va bien rigoler
excellence c'est parce que le move
or si je tombe sur un bon filon c'est
rude journée pour tsonga
et si tu lâches je lâche en syrie
le chef se sont enfin on peut dire que
vous avez tous étaient sur le fond tous
moins de évidemment